all right cool but actually
I know that if I go for a 30 year old
woman they're going to be stuck in their
ways if you both smoke I've got a 20
year old woman there 30 year old woman
there both of you smoke
I can actually probably change a 20 year
old woman but a 30 year old I don't
think there's going to see much time two
are supposed to become one flesh anyways
right right so and that's like that's
how they used to view it because they
were one yeah I think the main question
here is if she was to date a bus driver
will the relationship work no one won't
work because he's not providing for her
he's not being the superior person in
the relationship so what's the point of
her going for a bus driver what for the
sake of seeing she has babies I think
she knows it's just not gonna work like
a bus driver probably doesn't know as
much as her probably hasn't had as much
experience as her they probably do not
have the same thing in common in terms
of mediums experience does she have she
talks for a living yeah but she probably
has experience of like she's probably in
big rooms with people they have like
really serious conversations she
probably can't have them conversations
of a bus driver so I think the reason
why she's saying that is because she
knows with her bus driver the
relationship is just not gonna work I'm
sure you can agree that a man's roles to
provide right so if you can't provide
the relationship it's just it's not
gonna work I think in his role is to
provide if you're a traditional woman if
you deserve to be provided for so what
is a traditional woman could be like
State like what is that I think I think
in general like what our great
grandmothers were our grandmas
imagine
more so yeah yeah I mean I really don't
think they exist anymore to be honest
but like virgin
um usually like submissive to their
husband Cooks cleans no good with
children has experience with children no
sewing isn't like I think we know in
general what a traditional woman is like
we're not we're not dumb you know so
um I I think it's entitled to ask for
something you don't deserve and that's
why I think this is crazy because she's
asking for something she doesn't deserve
she's asking for traditional treatment
when she doesn't deserve it I think
that's a bit harsh to say that she's
entitled only because obviously when you
compare it to like traditional women the
grandmothers and stuff like that they
didn't have an option to become TV
presenter their whole life goal was to
be a housewife and have race kids like
women have been able to work since like
the 20s but this is what I'm saying is
that like where can TV presenters two
different things that this woman is on
TV every day she's having fun she's
living her dream she's kicking back like
I personally found on TV having fun I
don't really know at 39 I'd want to come
back to a however year old bus driver
but he's probably riding his bus and
he's going to be so happy to see you
know his pretty wife on the TV and he
comes home and he sees her as well I
feel like this is better a bus driver
error
you come home right and you lay in bed
and there's air
but you know that's different and
there's ore or there's a bus driver or
the equivalent of an average job because
she's an average tit but that's what I'm
saying she's asking me like if if like
if he's getting on my nerves I'd rather
air but I feel like bus drivers work
long hours anyway so 90 of the time is
probably going to be airing that bed but
I just feel like it's harsh for her to
be entitled just because men like so
she's 40 right what does life look like
for her at 60 70. like we're supposed to
live to be 90 years old
what is she gonna do the last 40 years
of her life her looks are gone so TV's
over I don't know she doesn't she's
invisible to men because like men aren't
really checking for women over the age
of like 45 50 you know 50 if you're
lucky
um so now what is the second half of her
life look like the thing is is obviously
personally like I don't know but
obviously she said she just doesn't want
to spend it with a bus driver so if
that's what sis doesn't want then that's
what sis doesn't want and maybe like who
knows maybe that debate actually sparked
up and woke up a bus driver and he's
thinking you know what I'm really gonna
work harder or maybe you know what
they're like [__] it she's 40 I can't
really I'm gonna keep driving my bus
like but my point my point isn't even
really hurt like I don't really give a
[__] about this girl right my point is
like average women still feel entitled
to above average men and we're so
delusional to think that we are going to
get them when what does she bring to the
table as a 39 year old news presenter so
would you say in the bus drivers above
average and she's average I'm saying
she's average
um maybe even below average at 40. as
into what she can bring to a guy and a
bus driver is an average man so they're
like equals kind of yeah and she thinks
she's above it so what about men so Paul
would you um marry a cleaner
do you guys think you guys would have a
lot in common
it's funny I actually want to date
someone I like prefer it when we have
nothing in common so how would the
relationship survive like what would you
guys discuss if you guys I don't I don't
really think you need to talk yeah
so then that would basically be like
dating air exactly no I feel like you
should talk to her I was thinking about
this the other day I was like do men
really want to listen to us talk
absolutely you know I have deep
conversations you have to really talk to
my friends not you just never talk I
think it's very attractive when um you
were the partner and they've got
something that can educate you yeah yeah
yeah
no I think girls talk they don't want to
hear oh did you remember what my friend
they don't want to hear that but if it's
something learning knowledgeable thank
you
um yeah absolutely that's that's what
they I think one is that's what I'm
saying like what's the news report we're
gonna learn from a bus
drivers
but when you think about it is like when
you just look at it she obviously she
reports the news like in General she
just comes across she might know a lot
more but obviously he might end up
learning way more from her because
obviously she reports things exactly
it's kind of Vice Versa but at the same
time he's probably going to learn more
from her than she will from him so it's
like in that sense she kind of is valid
to like you know maybe she wants to like
learn from her partner like maybe that's
why she doesn't want a bus driver I feel
like she could date a lawyer or she
could date a shopkeeper or she could
date a teacher but a bus driver like
let's be real like there's actual levels
to things in this life and I feel like
that's they would have absolutely
nothing in common and I'm not even
judging it due to his pockets I'm
judging it the compatibility what are
they going to talk about what they're
going to discuss what they're going to
have in common yeah I feel like in that
aspect she's allowed to say that this is
not going to work and she's better off
dating dating someone in history people
didn't have anything in common like his
story like having similar hobbies to a
guy that's a new thing no you have to
have something okay okay Hunter
Gathering what did they have in common
survival
[Laughter]
okay even on the farm like they did
different roles like having similar
interests is a new thing
no but I'm saying they both did
different roles on the farm like they
didn't do the same things like the woman
was more in the house the guy was more
in the field but managing that whole
property that was what they had right
they had the family in common and so you
would still have the family in common in
this situation but we're talking a lot
about like traditional women but I just
want to understand like you guys's
thoughts on traditional men and how
common that is these days do you feel
like it's common as well that do men
play their part do they play their
position I think that there's more
traditional men than traditional women
okay and then can we just go over what a
traditional man is just in brief just um
I would say a guy that wants to protect
and provide um I think I've been
researching more about like guys
providing
um and I don't know what what 50 to 60
000 is in the UK but you can actually
live off of a lot of 50 to 60 000 that's
about what like 40K yeah so on 40K um
you can feed roughly a family of four
five if you if you do it right
in London you might have to go to the
suburbs yeah that's what I'm saying like
you can homeschool the kids if you want
and you go out into the suburbs and he
commutes to work you can do it people
just don't want to the thing is most
guys naturally want to be providers on
protectors but most women set standards
that are way too high for most men to
meet that's the issue can you give us an
example of a stand at that's high too
high okay can I can I give you one yeah
if you want to have your nails done the
rest of your life yes and you want
makeup the rest of your life would could
you go without that expense for a family
of course for a family a lot of women
won't
well I've heard your perspective on the
makeup there a lot of a lot of women
like won't go down in lifestyle for a
family I would do that for my family no
no you you might you might but I'm
saying like a lot of women won't because
I was speaking to a woman who raised
like four or five kids on like 40 to 50K
and she was like giving examples of jobs
you can go for and I I can't remember it
exactly but she was giving examples like
for women of jobs you can go for in like
places you can find those men and like
how you can do it and she's like you
only like when you go down to one income
it's less money and if you homeschool
the kids it's less money if you grow
your own food it's the funny less money
but like most people refuse to do that
now that's interesting but even on the
thing about maintaining like appearances
and stuff makeup knows like for me
personally like I believe in enhancing
what you naturally have so yeah I've got
makeup on I actually don't wear that
much makeup I don't have eyelashes on I
wear mascara these are my these are my
real nails no no no I'm just saying as
an example of the fact that I take time
to actually look after my natural
qualities so if I didn't to like come
off it I can not wear makeup tomorrow
and I couldn't get my nails done
tomorrow and if all the shops ended and
everything all of this I could survive
and look good naturally I take care of
myself like I I look after myself so
that's why I think women need to
concentrate on more than just adding on
things women make 80 of consumer buying
decisions like women are bad with money
bad like think about it metal that means
men only spend 20 of like what is it
because of the appearances right no I
think it's because women were more
impulsive we just make more emotional
decisions yeah I think when it comes to
maintenance and things I think every
woman should look after themselves I
think the mistake that us females make
is we spend too much money looking after
themselves like there's so many ways to
look nice and do it on a budget like for
example with me I've always been a girly
girl I've always loved fashion and when
I got like my first few jobs I used to
spend so much money on clothes and would
have nothing left then I decided let me
just be a fashion influencer and I
haven't spent money on clothes in like
the last three years so there's and even
as well sometimes I resell those clothes
so there's smart ways to look good but
actually do it on a budget so for all
the girls watching this I strongly
encourage you to not fall into that
pressure or feeling like you have to
spend thousands every month just to look
good because you really don't the woman
I spoke to said she spent I think it was
less than 100 a year and clothes for
five kids because they would do resales
and hand-me-downs but her kids that
takes a lot of time and patience I guess
correct but like most women don't want
to do it yeah
it's important for men though as well do
you think yeah I do actually important I
do not as important not as important not
as important I feel like hygiene is
definitely important because no one
wants a smelly man but the reason why is
not important because for women that's
not what we look for I feel like our
main priority is someone like membership
doesn't provide you know not someone
that's going to be aesthetically
pleasing to us and that's the problem of
society today men care more about Gucci
than actually going out and having an
Healthy Man care more about Gucci yeah
men care more about Gucci and having an
LV belt and looking nice than actually
you know going out and having a job
again the numbers just don't support you
because men aren't really spending money
like that
I think Modern Men especially men in my
generation no I'm telling you if you
look at the numbers of like the money
spent it's not it's women that are
spending money it's not men there might
be like exceptions but again you
probably you guys don't see 80 of men
like they're invisible to you you don't
notice the guy at Tesco you don't notice
the guy and I'm
like I'm I'm saying like for a moment
you find 80 of men is unattractive well
statistics don't lie so I can't even
argue that yeah no I think it's
important for a man to take care of
himself but just to answer your question
like if you're talking like getting like
facials or just skin care skin care is
so important like across the board I
think we all need to take that seriously
men manicures pedicures that's great do
that I'm gonna Read Super chats
manicures
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible